hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and in this video i'm going to talk
about the delta scalper you know and
what it does and how to use it
effectively because you know the delta
scalper is a tool that i released
several years ago actually was one of
the first
additional order flow analysis tools
after the order flows trader footprint
chart that we released
that analyzes specifically the delta and
i'll be talking about how it performed
today in the micro e minis you know the
mes gold futures and euro currency
futures now again you know i released
this
tool uh several years ago and you know
other
gurus other vendors have tried copying
it and but they don't really understand
it and it that's a problem because you
know if you're trying to buy something
right you should buy the original now
i'm not going to get into what delta is
because i've gotten done many many
videos on that and i've explained that
ad nauseam so hopefully you could
understand by now what order float delta
analysis is and many traders actually
still struggle to grasp the importance
of delta analysis right they have
difficulty understanding that sometimes
there's a very strong hand in the market
you know because after all right we're
taught that for every buyer there's a
seller right and vice versa right
trading is a zero-sum game you can't uh
sell unless you're selling it to a buyer
and you can't buy unless there's a
seller so what delta scalper does is it
alerts you who is in control of the
market
and how does it do that is it looks at
the relationship between the different
delta numbers as they come in and
analyze them so it's doing this in real
time so it's giving you
generating for you buy or sell signals
in real time as they occur which allows
you to get in at the earliest possible
time so what delta scalper does is it
alerts you to areas in the market where
buyers are drying up and sellers are
getting stronger you know that would be
a sign of a down move and also where
sellers are getting less and buyers are
starting to dominate that would kick off
a nice up move so let's take a look at
the charts okay
just so you can see it in action so i'll
start off with the uh
what do i start off with the mes
okay not that shark sorry
so i'll start off in the mes here we go
all right so
the default settings okay i'll just take
it off
the default settings first it's seven
one and one right what you're going to
be looking at is the look back bars the
negative delta strength and the positive
delta strength okay and so this is when
you first load the indicator this is the
setting seven one and one okay you don't
really have to worry about the signal
box height
data because that's more on how it's
displayed on the chart so just go back
to today today is april 13th
okay so
you can see with the default settings
here let me just scrunch this chart up
here let me get the crosshairs on here
so you're seeing some sells in the
morning right as the market sells off
then the buys as the market starts to
rally up um sell as it starts to come
off now that's with the default settings
now
there's a look back feature meaning you
know it's going to be looking for swing
highs and swing lows that's what this is
here the look back bars 7. now you could
actually
turn that off which would be to disable
it
which would be zero
okay now i'm going to keep it at the
base strength of one and one i mean
you're not going to set a negative delta
strength of zero and zero and a positive
of zero because there's no point you
you're not analyzing anything the
basically the three levels that you'd
want to keep it at is one two and three
i don't go above
two actually i just use one and two okay
one is the base level that um will work
on pretty much every market you know if
you want a little bit stronger you jump
up to two so i'm turning off the look
back bars okay so it's basically going
to try to alert me um you know anytime
there's an instance of the delta scalper
signal
so let's just uh turn it on here at zero
look back bars
and you can see it says up here
calculating
okay in the top so
again you know depending on how much
data that you have loading
you know is going to be how fast it is
right i think on this chart i've got
about two weeks of data
but you can see it's still pretty quick
so now you're seeing a lot more signals
okay
now
again you don't have to use that's it
with the look back turned off you could
actually set it to a lower level or
seven is quite strong for you know swing
highs or swing lows you know you can set
it to one
and
let's see you know it's going to give
you less signals than when it's at zero
but it's going to give you more signals
than when it's set at um
at seven okay
turn it off you can see up here it says
calculating up at the top all right so
now you can see there's a bit more
signals it's a little bit more
active than having to look back at seven
and there's less signals than if you
have it
set to zero
so
what about if you want to make it a bit
stronger okay
so you could change it to two and two
now
the way it's calculating it um you know
actually each level that you go up from
one to two is doubling the strength so
if you go from two to three
you're doubling it from you're not just
going up incrementally right so from one
to you imagine it's you know one to two
and then two essentially would be you
know you're doubling the two and it's
becoming four instead of three in that
sense so each level it doubles so if you
were to go to
you know four it'd be like 16 times the
strength so
set it at two and i'll keep
the look back at at one now when i go
higher in delta strength i tend to
decrease the look back bars or even turn
them off so let's take a look on
look back set to one with a stronger
delta strength of two and two right you
need
positive and negative delta strength um
i tend to i keep them the same i don't
vary and i don't keep one at one like
negative at one positive at two uh you
should keep them the same
so here right you can see there's
less signals right you still got the
look back of one now
if i was going to have it look back of
seven there'd be very few signals i
wouldn't use a delta strength of two
with um a look back of seven but let's
take a look on how it's going to look
with the lookback bars set to zero
meaning it's just
signaling anytime the conditions are met
okay so let's give it a second come up
here now
one recommendation you know a best
practice if you're using the indicator
use the tabs you know and you could keep
the different charts open that you want
to have rather than keep flipping
through um the charts or sorry rather
than keep going and changing it and
pulling up a new chart and then changing
it again and you just you know you start
out your your day with a different
you know with your different markets
that you're looking at with the delta
scalper loaded on there all right so
here it is
on the way down you know on the way up
okay so there's some decent signals
there
now let's take a look at
gold futures
okay
so i'll keep it at the same settings of
2 for positive and 2 for negative
and they'll look back you know we'll
keep it at zero for now so
let's just scrunch this up a bit
here
again gold had this
some interesting movement this morning
starting
you know during the the european session
and u.s session pretty much sideways but
anyway let's just go here
okay so
you can see the strength is set to two
right with look back of zero now if i
have
let's just
step it down to
strength of one i'll keep the look back
at zero
okay
if i should close this or
keep it up so you're seeing a lot more
signals
okay now
obviously if you set the look back to i
don't know we'll set it to seven right
the default seven one and one
okay so you're seeing the buys here sell
here so you know a little sell here a
little cell here
small moves as this market's going
sideways
but you're catching you know hopefully
you're catching that big move
try it with the setting of look back of
one
and really what you want to do right for
your market you know for me i
i have
the markets that i follow i have
settings that i
prefer for those markets and i stick to
them i don't keep changing them intraday
all right so this is one one and one
this is and the settings i'm talking
about one one and one
zero two and two these are the settings
that i use
okay and there's a reason for that um
which is sort of explained in the user
manual on on what the delta scalper is
about okay so you can see some nice uh
moves up and down there okay
um let's take a look at uh euro currency
6e euro fx
and again i'll just take you through the
settings
same settings um you know since we're
talking about it so this one is one one
and one so it's a look back of one
right negative delta strength of one
positive delta strength of one
okay so
you can see there's some
yeah it did manage to catch this nice
move from you know what is that 65 all
the way up
you know above 109
right and some small moves there now
if you are using the default settings
right seven one and one
this is what it would look like
okay so you see seven one and one the
settings up here at the top again still
catching that major move up there
catching some down moves here but you
are getting stopped out
but again these are small stops right
you're getting short at uh 108 60 and a
half you know you're stopped out at 63.
okay fine you know you could take those
small losses now
let's uh make it a bit stronger okay
now i'm gonna set the look back to zero
i'm gonna make the strength uh two
zero two and two
okay so the
negative delta strength the positive
delta strength are
basically doubled
and again you know it's catching some of
these nice this nice move down this nice
move up nice move up let's move down
it's a little move down so
again you know you can
i don't say play around with the
settings but you know you should find
the settings that you're going to be
most comfortable with using if you want
it stronger
with fewer signals or if you want it
um
i don't say weaker but you know you want
to see more signals you want to be more
active in your trading uh you might want
to
set it at uh uh
above the base level of one and one
so hopefully you found this video
helpful
and you know again you know if you're
interested in a delta scalper right now
we do have a special going on just go to
deltascalper.com
and
you know take advantage of the special
that's going on right now because it's
just going to last for a few days
so thanks and i'll see you guys on the
inside bye bye